alright guys it's time for a game the
way this game is going to work is that
I'm gonna ask a question about one of
you the other two have to yell out the
answer and whoever gets it right wins a
pair of Fandango movie tickets fantastic
ok so here we go
testing nice so I'm gonna start with a
question about Jen so this question is
for the two guys okay
what is Jennifer's middle name shreya
traitor now you show us the answer done
it is in fact straighter at by a hair oh
I don't know oh it's a great no it's
fine it's a joint okay great I didn't
realize that later you know my middle
name look at me
yeah I did know okay here's a question
for you - about Josh if Josh was not an
actor what job would he want to have uh
Oscar ballplayer oh he could be um
that's it have you told us this oh my
god is it something that yet you want to
work on oh oh honey you want to be a
zipline um I'm an outdoor yeah then
adventure - yeah so tickets for you
think about me what do I love what's my
passion okay here's the question about
Liam what is his favorite drink at a bar
um yeah but what it's complicated
because it'll do it sometimes sometimes
it's vodka tonic but then vodka soda
yeah well like when were touring and we
all have like wake up early then you
always go clean with vodka tonic vodka
soda
what is he talking to you I'll give you
a when he's drinking in the morning it's
a city in Russia man Oh Moscow Mule a
Moscow Mule good job I'm not drinking
like it's become with everything over
the last couple years yes yeah I'm Jamie
for you
farewell fair but that being said I have
heard you talk about Moscow Mule yeah
guys what is Jen's favorite song to do
karaoke believe me yes are you actually
saying that's something like I knew it
buddy I'm good I'm sorry what was this
about to be like I didn't win anything
and then I found this I'm saying a big
thing strongly not know what is Josh's
favorite all-time movie oh you're you
might not get you're like freaking no I
know that I won't get it right because
it's gonna be so dumb it might be a
movie started saying telling me to give
it to you I'm gonna get you God knows
and so I did show her soul but she just
deletes it
okay here's the last one for you too not
counting the two of you woody
but okay go ahead which cast member is
Liam going to miss the most
woody wait I gotta win there is before
you even finished it if it's not one of
us it's gotta be one no matter what the
question is yeah yeah let's count the
cards
well of online-armor I have to I got six
I got six tickets to a movie three god I
get one okay so I lose it I guess well
you're gratulations don't win another
one movie tickets everybody I want two
tickets you can avenge this loss next
year when I play but we do have a little
bonus prize for you Oh which is your own
personal Mockingjay picture of Jennifer
yeah hair card available outlet on
Fandango
oh sweet that's for you guys for playing
oh oh thank you great to see you and
great job I'm gonna see